[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
un país que sin duda atraviesa una grave
crisis política el líbano para ello me
acompañan en este estudio tres invitados
que ya les pasó a presentar melissa
barra es compañera de radio francia
internacional que ha estado varias veces
reportaje ando allí en líbano bienvenida
a melissa a la carlos nos acompañó
también logan perpiñán periodista
independiente especializado en oriente
medio' bienvenido hola nos acompaña
también kristen joven periodista en orán
21 bienvenido crist hola líbano
corrupción endémica hoy en primera plana
[Música]
bueno pues líbano cumplía hace tan sólo
unos días cien años de su fundación y lo
hacía intentando resurgir de sus cenizas
tras ya lo saben esas imágenes que a
todos nos asombraron este verano el
pasado 4 de agosto esa explosión en el
puerto de beirut que puso al descubierto
varios de los males que vive el país el
encargado de pilotar esta nueva etapa
como primer ministro es mustafá deep un
tecnócrata en medio de la crisis
sanitaria que vive el país con un índice
de desempleo en torno al 30 por ciento y
con más de la mitad de los 4 millones y
medio de libaneses que viven bajo el
umbral de la pobreza y sobre todo tendrá
que hacer frente al gran mal que asola
el país esa corrupción endémica en unos
instantes
vamos a plantear todas estas
circunstancias y vamos a entender mejor
vamos a comprender mejor el líbano pero
antes vamos a repasar cómo hacemos
siempre algunas portadas de prensa que
ilustran esta esta temática lo que le
jour el apocalipsis una portada que dice
todo tras el siniestro de este verano
recuerden la explosión de dos mil
setecientos cincuenta toneladas de
nitrato de amonio almacenadas de forma
insegura en el puerto de beirut aquí en
francia diario el agua
la obra de reconstrucción libanesa
hallada añade el diario católico que
esta reconstrucción que se tiene que dar
ahora en el país se da en un contexto de
total desesperanza entre la población
libanesa el club internacional
internacional se hace un aporte una
pregunta en su portada que hoy vamos a
trasladar a nuestros invitados y que
desde luego no tiene ni mucho menos una
fácil respuesta podemos salvar aún al
líbano bueno melissa lo primero tras las
imágenes que hemos visto este verano de
esa grave explosión en el puerto de
beirut en qué situación se encuentra
ahora mismo el líbano bueno hay hay
varias caras en realidad desde la crisis
primero humanitaria como lo decías la
mitad de los libaneses están viviendo
por debajo del umbral de pobreza y por
qué porque hay gente sin techo se
hablaba de 300 mil personas que no
tenían casa porque son casas muy
antiguas son cannes otomana son está
casas que estaban en un estado
deplorable y que se vinieron abajo está
el sistema sanitario sin electricidad o
en este momento hay tres horas de
electricidad al día si uno no tiene un
generador eléctrico
y también el agua que llega a las
montañas tienen que llegar de cierta
manera a beirut y no está llegando
porque no puede bombear porque falta
electricidad y lo podemos ver en las
imágenes de la explosión que ocurrió en
el puerto en el puerto también se
almacenaban lo estaba el silo los silos
de grano 85% de los granos del líbano
estaban ahí entonces estamos también
enfrentando una situación de emergencia
alimentaria terrible agreguémosle
desfalco being agreguemos la eso la
crisis de refugiados que todavía existe
hoy en día y detrás de todo eso es pues
está la peor crisis económica que ha
vivido el país lo hagan este siniestro
sin duda el último golpe de un país que
ya estaba en crisis previamente y quizá
no hayan que interpretarlo como una
causa sino más bien como una
consecuencia de la crisis no sin duda es
lo que te van muchos libaneses y muchas
libanesas que esta explosión de
contextualizada
es una consecuencia de la crisis de esta
crisis multidimensional
y hay que analizar un poco el contexto
yo estaba en líbano unos días antes de
la instrucción y cuando regrese el país
estaba estaba súper triste para este
pueblo porque yo estaba al despegue yo
estaba mirando por la ventana del avión
y pensando
beirut nunca te evitan triste nunca vi
tu gente tan desesperada sin esperanza
los cortes de electricidad son diarios
tres horas de cristal y es imposible
vivir así los hospitales faltan de todos
la revolución libanesa está confinada
desde desde unas semanas y bueno
pensamos estar está al final de una
historia y pensaba que puede pasar peor
y finalmente unos días después esta
expulsión vino y bueno resulta vamos que
300.000 personas están sin techo
y ahora el pueblo libanés tiene más
rabia contra sus élites porque éstos ni
abrieron ni una escuela ni un gimnasio
para acoger a estas 300.000 personas sin
techo es terrible luego vamos a intentar
explicar el reparto del poder en este
complejo país pero antes me gustaría
preguntarle por él el hombre encargado
de pilotar esta nueva etapa a finales de
agosto se designó el primer ministro el
diplomático es un y mustafa embajador a
estar en berlín hasta desde el año 2013
qué perfil tiene el nuevo primer
ministro y me gustaría preguntarte cris
se le concede crédito y esperanza
ahora mismo eso sí improbable no es
improbable pero es una persona es un
techno el tecnócrata pide pero tiene
tiene una posición consensual así
mientras la mayoría de los partidos en
líbano la mayoría de los partidos el
partido de hariri también ha desvelado
están dispuestos a ir adelante pero por
ejemplo por el hezbollah hay una
condición hay que bloquear la acción
e impuestos por los eeuu contra irán con
reyes volar por ejemplo no se puede
desarrollar un gobierno de unión
nacional
si uno de los partes está sancionado
normalmente para los eeuu esto puede ser
un daño por la iniciativa francesa a
partir de ahí el presidente macrón que
ha estado dos veces de visita a partir
de la explosión ha pedido reformas al
país reformas al nuevo primer ministro
por dónde deben ir esas estas reformas
que se piden para la ayuda para
canalizar esa ayuda internacional logan
es quien en este nuevo primer ministro
tiene unos retos que son casi imposible
imposible en serio porque primero tiene
que formar un gobierno es una cosa muy
complicada segundo tiene que hablar con
el fmi ya el líbano no habla con ellos
esta situación con el bloqueo de los
estados unidos y el bloqueo en
consecuencia del hezbollah y de la mal
ahora mismo para formar un gobierno le
pone una situación terrible el de
momento no sabemos casi nada de esta
persona solo que se queda murió desde
desde su investidura ya no habrá está
esperando a ver cómo puede salvar el
país pero de momento él no tiene la
solución ni nadie sabe cómo como va
estamos hablando de hezbollah pero me
gustaría explicar el contexto a todos
nuestros oyentes y telespectadores
cuando estamos hablando del líbano cómo
se produce hasta ahora ese reparto de
poder entre las comunidades del país no
sé quién lo quiere explicar crisis
explica no lo mira líbano no ha sido
establecido como un sistema confesional
por el mandato francesa en 1920 entre
1943 ha sido una encuesta que ha
dividido al país en influencias de las
comunidades religiosas entonces era
también para proteger la entonces
mayoría cristiana ahora es una minoría
garantizo que por ejemplo al presidente
siempre es un cristiano maronita al
presidente
el presidente del gobierno es un súbito
y la dirección del parlamento hay un hit
en asia el 10 de este se me está pre
configurado para que ustedes se imaginen
si la diferencia es que había una
ilusión demográfica
mientras tanto y esta situación un poco
muy tendido ha sido corregido por el
acuerdo de taif en 1989 en donde el
presidente cristiano obtuvo menos menos
poder y un establecimiento de una
igualdad entre musulmanes y cristianos
este sistema condicional se puede decir
es una protección por las comunidades
pero también es un bloqueo por el
desarrollo de la sociedad y lo que los
que la gente en la calle
critican lo más es una corrupción
endémica una corrupción que no es
directamente ligado a este sistema
profesional porque no se puede abolir
este sistema en 24 horas pero hay
necesitan una modificación radical de
ese sistema confesional y sobre todo de
medidas muy concretas contra la
corrupción y medidas sociales para
10 este sistema interno que explica
crisis se le incorporan además factores
externos de rescate una frase que dijo
el presidente de macrón de visita el
líbano si abandonamos líbano en manos de
las potencias regionales en alusión a
irán y arabia saudí habrá otra guerra
civil en el país recuerdan que el país
estuvo sumergido una grande
guerra civil entre el año 75 y el 90
corrígeme si me equivoco la frase de
macrón este riesgo es hoy por hoy real
en líbano bueno en lo personal yo creo
que es menos real que lo fue hace diría
5 ó 6 años es decir en el momento en que
el líbano estaba viviendo donde su
vecino siria una guerra civil donde él
mismo el país está implicado donde
facciones políticas militares estaban
implicadas en esa guerra era una época
también en la que había muchísimos
refugiados sirios en el país había un
odio profundo de los de una gran parte
de los libaneses hacia esa esa población
refugiada como lo fue en el 75 cuando
yo la guerra civil también era porque
una gran parte de los libaneses no
soportaba la presencia de refugiados
palestinos entonces cuando hubo la
guerra civil en siria hubo de nuevo esa
imagen de nuevo ese esa situación y
agregamos la de eso también que existía
el califato de la organización estado
islámica que está en las puertas del
líbano hubo atentados en el líbano en
barrios chiitas en barrios controlados
por el hezbollah decir que era una época
muy muy tensa hoy en día tengo la
impresión y de pronto loma me dirán lo
contrario que los libaneses nos ya no
están enfocados en esas cosas
tienen la mirada en queremos un cambio
político ya no está en una cuestión
confesional de bandos contra bandas es
todos están globalmente contra el
gobierno y además lo hagan creo que
estuvo en los campos de refugiados ahora
que lo comentaba a melissa creo que fue
el mes de julio como es la situación en
esos esos campos de refugiados terrible
terrible en los campos palestinos pueden
hablar situación antes era súper difícil
pero con la crisis económica
hay que entender que todo lo que venden
dentro del campo le compran fuera y los
precios ya están multiplicado por 7 por
7 o sea 1 la gente de líbano los
libaneses que tienen dinero casi no
pueden ir al supermercado los
restaurantes estaban casi vacíos es
súper complicado para todos pues hay que
imaginarse para personas para personas
que viven en un campo que no pueden
salir casi de este campo que tienen que
vivir dentro más el confinamiento ha
sido una explosión de problemas para
ellos y ahora se trata para ellos de
sobrevivir de un manera muy simple de
sobrevivir
por lo de la guerra civil bueno esta
amenaza hay que entender que hablan de
bueno amenazan de una guerra civil cada
vez que hay una cosa que pasa en líbano
hace años años años marco no inventó
nada es y era exactamente el discurso de
las élites libanesas al 17 de octubre
pasado al inicio de la revolución sois y
responsables de manifestar por rasga les
vais a provocar una guerra civil al
final hoy estoy totalmente de acuerdo
con melissa las cosas cambiaron desde el
17 de octubre pasado en las manifas
había chía sabía suníes había cristianos
todos se encontraron formaron grupos
juntos se unieron y hoy creo que no hay
este riesgo no existe pero hay
injerencias extranjeras iraní saudí
turquía porque no se puede olvidar
tampoco hay la amenaza israelí y los
eeuu que desempeñan un papel muy
importante del país vamos a dejarlo
algún momento en este punto de las
injerencias les voy a volver a preguntar
por ello a vuelta de esta breve pausa
enseguida volvemos
[Música]
el independentismo catalán está muy
debilitado y unas nuevas elecciones
anticipadas en la comunidad autónoma
parecen inevitables en pocos días se
despega a la sentencia del tribunal
supremo español que seguramente
inhabilitada al presidente catalán el
quinto capo que como vemos el caso de la
pancarta a favor de los presos catalanes
que estaba en la fachada del palacio de
la generalitat en plena campaña
electoral pese a su prohibición en caso
de que se confirmase esta inhabilitación
pues hoy pongo una parte la policía
catalana teme unos nuevos disturbios en
las calles como los que sacudió en
barcelona el año pasado y por otra se
convocarían unos nuevos comicios en los
próximos meses pero no está nada claro
el que el independentismo de la derecha
y la izquierda que gobiernan en
coalición actualmente el puesto pueda
volver a ganar y sobre todo gobernar
juntos
ya que hace meses que la división entre
ambos partidos es evidente
[Música]
a 6 años del referéndum por la
independencia de escocia la opinión
pública ha cambiado en favor de
independizarse del resto del reino
unido- los vientos soplan en favor de un
esposo independiente según las últimas
encuestas de opinión 53 por ciento
votaría en favor de independizarse del
reino unido según los expertos y el
creciente apoyo para una escocia
independiente se debe a la salida del
reino unido de la unión europea el
'break' a la que los escoceses siempre
se han opuesto además la primera
ministra de escocia al independentista
nicola sturgeon asegura que si hay bases
y fundamentos para un segundo referéndum
sin embargo el gobierno central de
westminster advierte que no autorizará
una segunda consulta y que el tema quedó
resuelto de una vez y para siempre en el
referéndum de 2014
[Música]
que ve que es una provincia famosa por
ser una isla francesa y católica en un
país de mayoría inglesa y protestante
también por los dos referendos en los
80s y 90s que decidieron por márgenes
estrechos que que dec se quedaría en
canadá
actualmente quería que está habiendo
resurgido nacionalismo bajo el liderazgo
de fonz fue luego un ex 'para' tista y
ahora líder de la coalición a venir
quebec o que recientemente el ente de
vigilancia que hace cumplir las normas
sobre el uso del francés en la provincia
recibió una inyección de 5 millones de
dólares aún así otro referendo
independentista parece no ser una opción
para el eco para el apoyo público ha
fluctuado aunque las más recientes
encuestas registran que alrededor de una
tercera parte de la población favorece
la independencia como explicó la
profesora de sociología clerc dijo a
france 24 cada vez más personas en la
provincia se identifican con una
identidad quebequense aunque querer la
independencia por esta razón es cada vez
menos común
[Música]
todas las semanas tenemos una cita para
hablar de mujeres en ellas hoy hablamos
de nuestra diversidad nuestros logros y
nuestras luchas constantes aquí
entrevistamos a las que generan el
cambio en el mundo y les contamos sus
historias
[Música]
el día soy en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
pues continuamos en primera plana hoy
hablando del rompecabezas del líbano
tras las imágenes que seguro vieron este
verano de esa explosión en el puerto de
beirut y la grave crisis que azota el
país a todos los niveles a nivel social
a nivel económico a nivel político lo
hacemos con kristen home periodista en
orient 21 mi compañera está elisa barra
de radio france internacional que ha
hecho numerosos reportajes allí en
líbano y luego en perpiñán periodista
independiente especializado en medio
oriente
antes de la pausa estaba logan
comentando el tema de las injerencias
crisis y le trasladó esa pregunta es a
ese riesgo que avanzaba macrón sobre
otra guerra civil posible si abandonamos
líbano creo que recuerdo que fue la
frase exacta en manos de las potencias
del entorno y esas potencias en ese
pueblo sobre todo se refería a esa
dicotomía entre arabia saudí e irán ese
riesgo y por hoy cuán real es claro que
sí pero al presidente francés macro
olvide que no solamente hay irán y
arabia de seguridad
también hay también israel y la turquía
y no hay que olvidar que también hay una
indiferencia del fondo monetario
internacional
porque esta intervención económica ha
sido uno de los problemas actuales que
una implementación de una política
ultraliberal
hay que saber que en los años 50 limón
era considerado como la suiza del medio
oriente hoy en día no hay nada habían
sido planes de reestructuración que es
un gran problema ahora porque si algunas
dicen que a la ayuda internacional tiene
que pasar por ongs
quiere decir también que es una
privatización acelerada no se puede
pagar bomberos su sistema de educación
no el sistema de salud
solamente con jóvenes necesitan un
estado quien será democratizado y donde
el peso del sistema confesional y de la
corrupción endémica sería eliminado esto
es en el
hablaba ahora chris de esas ongs que
tienen que garantizar de alguna forma el
suministro de sistema social en medio de
esta crisis sanitaria y hablaba antes me
lista de los cortes de electricidad
quiero preguntar a los tres que conocen
bien el líbano como es el día a día de
los de los libaneses hacías mención esos
cortes de electricidad me imagino que en
mitad de la pandemia que sistema social
tienen bueno
yo no estuve en el líbano después de la
explosión pero sí viví unos años y antes
de que se hablara de crisis económica
antes de que se hablara de todos los
problemas actuales ya había problemas de
electricidad es decir que los
apartamentos o las casas que no tienen
un generador en general se esperan a que
tengan dos horas de corte al día de
electricidad cuál sea el barrio cuál sea
el nivel de ingresos
el agua siempre es un problema por
ejemplo no existe agua potable de la
llave en el líbano es decir que la gente
siempre compra botellones gigantes de
agua para poder tomar y como le decía a
crisis que estamos en un sistema ultra
liberal es decir que haya funcionamos
por seguros médicos pagados funcionamos
con uno paga el servicio de las basuras
para que le recoja la basura en frente
de la casa todo es privado hay muy poco
que es público entonces imaginemos ahora
en un país un amigo libanés me decía
solíamos ser la suiza del medio oriente
hoy somos venezuela del medio oriente
entonces imaginemos hoy en día todos los
problemas que venían de antes como se
han agrandado tras un año y medio de
crisis económica y tres de exclusión
vamos a avanzar con algunas preguntas
que me gustaría contextualizar y dejar
claro en este programa ya que estamos
dando una visión tan amplia de lo que es
el líbano por ejemplo logan el peso
actual de hezbollah recuerden el partido
chiita milicia libanés en el país como
ha sido su evolución en los últimos
meses cuál es el peso actual de
hezbollah en el país
esta revolución ha sido un poco
complicado para el hezbollah la
revolución de octubre porque el
hezbollah históricamente ha sido siempre
en el campo de los pobres y de los
débiles
ha sido un momento difícil porque en
este inicio de la revolución había
grandes grandes manifestaciones en
bastiones días en navata sentir en la
beca así que ha sido un poco complicado
y estaban en plan a ver hay que quedar
un poco tranquilo porque si hay un
riesgo de que recibir intentado
intentando defender a la población sin
tomar parte en esta revolución estaba
cuando en traducía así ha sido súper
complicado luego se adaptó hay que
entender una cosa en el hezbollah tiene
dos intereses supremos primero en
mantener sus armas y segundo bueno
tratar de la amenaza israelí y defender
el país israel ataca mañana porque el
ejército libanés es súper débil pues son
los dos elementos fundamentales para el
hezbollah son los dos después la
política interna es otra cosa tiene
interés sí pero para ellos más
importantes las armas israel
tras meses de protestas hezbollah
recuperador no se ha recuperado parte de
la legitimidad perdida en medio de esta
crisis sanitaria donde ha intentado
implicar a miles de voluntarios para
intentar paliar de alguna forma la
situación de crisis interior y del país
esto le ha dotado actualmente cierta
legitimidad de nueva gente hubo la
crisis su legitimidad ha sido granizando
en después 2007 cuando ganó una guerra
contra israel y después tomó posiciones
en el gobierno lo que era nuevo por la
desvela entonces está tratando de
recuperar un poco de lo de la
movilización popular pero tanto también
está perdiendo porque como no es capaz
de pronunciar de tomar medidas sociales
para
para mejorar un poco esta crisis está
perdiendo un poco de popularidad
hay que saber que el hezbollah es
ciertamente uno de los partidos los
menos corruptos de todos los partidos
pero el de facto que estás parte del
gobierno o del gobierno anterior también
la gente le ven como parte del sistema y
el sistema tiene que ser modificado
radicalmente aún si podemos discutir
cómo modificar este sistema confesional
nuestra
hagámoslo hagámoslo cómo se modifica
este sistema confesional que parece que
está siempre es la pieza la pieza
angular siempre que hablamos de líbano
es decir este arbitraje sectario del que
podemos debatir si establece una
corrupción endémica a partir del cómo se
le mete mano para entendernos bueno con
qué criterios con que quien lo hace
además es una especie de esperanza que
realmente muy reciente es decir que de
la misma manera como explica la crisis
el sistema gubernamental el sistema
parlamentario es más o menos igual es
decir que tenemos varios varias
religiones comunidades las vamos a
llamar
en un acierto
y unas cuotas mínimas en el parlamento y
que se pueden asegurar tener el apoyo de
atrás desde 2018 una micro reforma de
del código electoral del parlamento que
permitió la entrada pequeña por primera
vez de partidos independientes y eran
partidos que la sociedad civil quería es
decir que hubo por ejemplo en 2015 hubo
en elecciones municipales y vimos crecer
partidos como byron madinat y que eran
de la sociedad civil que ya no tenían
nada que ver con ninguna comunidad
adentro había personas de comunidades
muy diferentes y a partir de eso son
personas a crear algunos partidos
independientes que poco a poco están
entrando dentro del parlamento hoy en
día sólo tienen diez escaños no es mucho
porque hay como 130 no pero permite que
se les está dando más visibilidad
este arbitraje sectario del que estamos
hablando todo el rato y refleja lo que
es hoy por hoy la sociedad el líbano es
decir quizá en nuestros oyentes nuestros
espectadores estén acciones la pregunta
es decir todo este nivel de política se
plasma en realidad en lo que es el
líbano de 2020 en la calle o no el
líbano iuc rifai geográficamente súper
dividido en zonas y eso para alguien que
no conoce el líbano school planes
personales líbano es muy complicada sí
claro pero se puede hacer de manera
distinta a dar el norte es no hay muchos
uñas en el norte hay muchos chichas en
el sur en la década también los
cristianos en una parte de beirut si se
puede hacer muy fácil muy fácilmente una
mapa luego estas divisiones ahora son
menos visibles por lo de la revolución
de octubre y es el único paso que yo
esta revolución porque es esta
revolución en un logro cambiar el
sistema
el eslogan era killing y aniquiló todos
es todos pero todos siguen el poder
ahora mismo y esto es el reto de de los
liberales
hay quien tienen que luchar y luchar más
para intentar construir algo nuevo y con
el caso de este primer ministro muchos
líderes dicen bueno es parte del sistema
es parte de lo mismo y si es parte pues
hay que sacar todos estos intentar con
algo nuevo como no sabemos y es un fallo
de esta revolución porque no tiene
propuestas claras pero dicen bueno ya
tenemos que poner fuera a todos estos
intentar algo de nuevo tomar riesgos
porque la revolución de sonríe es un
riesgo cambiar el sistema es un riesgo
si es posible uno nadie lo sabe ni yo ni
ellos ni nadie así que bueno en el
futuro nos dieron también disculpas
virus también que el líbano fue uno de
los pocos países que no tuvo su
primavera árabe no lo tuvo en un momento
en que lo miraba y mira lo que pasaba en
síria mira lo que pasa en egipto mira lo
que está pasado porque un poquito en
jordania también y decía nosotros
creemos lo mismo pero nunca se llegó a
la revolución de pronto hoy sea el
momento y de hecho el preámbulo de la
constitución libanesa
que el sistema confesional lista tiene
que acabarse en poco a poco pero dice
que tendrá un fin no sabemos cuándo
crisis me gustaría si ninguna de las
demandas principales del movimiento
popular actual pero también del partido
comunista libanés que es bastante fuerte
pero que no es una organización
confesional es una sola circunscripción
en líbano
lo que quiere decir que un partido puede
presentarse en todo el líbano y obtener
sedes en el parlamento pero hay que
saber también que el sistema actual
confesional con distintos
circunscripciones garantiza una
protección de los distintos comunidades
sean religiosos o no religiosos
como como es bastante bien un
modelo federal que puede ser una
protección contra la opresión incómoda
como contra el otro se han analizado
este tipo de modelos para el caso de
líbano es decir si fuese fuera una sola
circunscripción los riesgos que se
podrían asumir respecto a la falta de
representatividad de comunidades todo
esto está analizado
está analizando hoy enseña porque yo sé
que por ejemplo
el movimiento sea como el hezbolá no es
en contra porque como la evolución
demográfica agrega ya más jazz hoy que
hace un siglo
ellos están en favor de una sola 5 de
circunscripción puede ser algo más
democrático que el sistema actual
confesional en donde cada organización
confesional está diciendo a su propia
comunidad más que la totalidad de la
población porque vamos a dejar ahí
porque no tengo tiempo para más ha sido
pues muy ilustrativo hablar de algo tan
complejo como es la realidad del líbano
con tres personas que lo conocen tanto
como mis invitados de muchísimas gracias
logan melissa y cristian todos ustedes
hasta la próxima semana aquí en primera
plana muchas gracias
[Música]